[Musik]
Reichenbach Baden-Württemberg seit
Walter Ernst seine Frau nicht mehr zu
Hause pflegen kann haben sie nur noch
gemeinsame Nachmittage und finanzielle
Sorgen
heute sind wir gut drauf miteinander
denn das Pflegeheim seiner Frau schickt
jeden Monat hohe Rechnungen
3.300 Euro sollen sie selbst zuzahlen
Geld das mal für den Lebensabend gedacht
war geht nun fürs Pflegeheim drauf
das haben wir gedacht ja dass man schöne
Lebensabend miteinander verbringen und
jetzt ist alles weg geht alles weg
keine Flugreisen keine Kreuzfahrten
stets genügsam gelebt fast 50 Jahre
gearbeitet zusammen stolze 3000 Euro
Rente zu wenig für den Eigenanteil im
Pflegeheim
hab kein Geld mehr
von der Rente durch alles weg für seinen
eigenen Lebensunterhalt muss der
85-Jährige jetzt auf Ersparnisse
zurückgreifen so will es das Gesetz das
Sozialamt springt erst ein wenn alles
verbraucht ist weiter ernst hat
ausgerechnet in einem Jahr ist es soweit
und dann bin ich in Sozialfall
und ihre Frau auch und meine Frau auch
dass sie praktisch ein ganzes leben
arbeiten und dann sind sie
Sozialhilfeempfänger es kann doch nicht
sein
die Pflegeversicherung übernimmt nur
einen Teil der Heimkosten den anderen
müssen die Bewohner selbst aufbringen
doch dieser eigenanteiler weist sich
inzwischen als fast ohne Boden aktuell
muss ein Heimbewohner bundesweit im
Durchschnitt
2468 Euro im Monat zu zahlen zum
Vergleich die Durchschnittsrente beträgt
gerade mal 1000 Euro
Roding in Bayern ab dem Jahr 2022
sollten die Eigenanteile deutlich sinken
je länger man im Heim wohnt so hatte es
die Bundesregierung versprochen
das ist jetzt der erste neunte 22 doch
was ihnen als großer Wurf der Politik
präsentiert wurde geht nicht auf
Angehörige wie Ida Porsch und ihr Sohn
Thilo Zahlen bald wieder drauf wegen
gestiegener Personalkosten die nächste
Preiserhöhung fürs Pflegeheim des Vaters
steht schon an die letzte ist gerade mal
vier Monate her wissen Sie denn jetzt um
wie viel es noch mal steigt
ich habe von anderen gehört zwischen 40
und 60 Prozent wir haben für eine Januar
zwar die Rechnung schon erhalten aber
noch mit den alten Preisen
womöglich werden sie dann bald mehr als
vorher zahlen und obwohl der Vater von
der Entlastung profitieren sollte müssen
Sie immer weiter vom Ersparten dazu
schießen
also vom Vater wird jetzt ich denke mal
so vielleicht ein Jahr noch reichen und
dann
schauen wir mal
melden Sie ihn zum Sozialamt an
ja ist ja nicht möglich weil das Haus
und da ist und dann geht ihm das Haus
drauf
ich hätte hier schon alt werden wollen
was schaut aufscheinend nicht so aus
Fernsehen
Vater Porsch kann von 1000 Euro Rente
seinen Heimplatz nicht bezahlen
inzwischen geht für die Eigenanteile
sein Vermögen drauf
geht von 100.000 Euro mit Sicherheit
nicht mehr viel ab
Tag für Tag fährt der Sohn seinen Vater
spazieren macht täglich Erinnerungsfotos
seit mehr als vier Jahren in gleichen
Zeitraum sind die Eigenanteile im
Pflegeheim explodiert
insgesamt ist die Entwicklung jetzt doch
in den letzten Jahren ganz deutlich nach
oben wohin geht es dann kann ich mir
dann irgendwann nur noch ein Heimplatz
leisten wenn ich Sozialhilfe bin
das ist für ein Großteil der Bevölkerung
zu erwarten ja
in Sachsens Landkreisen gehört die
Sozialhilfe in Pflegeheimen schon jetzt
zu den größten Posten bei den
Sozialausgaben der
Bundesgesundheitsminister müsse dringend
prüfen ob die Pflegeversicherung der
Lebenswirklichkeit noch gerecht werde
fordert die sächsische Landesregierung
erst seit der Freitag ins Pflegeheim Zug
ist sie ein Fall für Sozialamt ihre
Rente geht komplett für den Eigenanteil
drauf und reicht doch nicht aus
fast 2000 Euro inklusive Witwenrente die
waren für die 80-Jährige zum Leben mehr
als genug bis sie ins Pflegeheim musste
ich habe zwei Renten
aber die reichen nicht
zwei Renten wieso unterstützt werden
aber hätten Sie jemals gedacht ein
Sozialfall zu werden
Gott deswegen
ich muss ihn ehrlich drüber nachdenken
was mit mir passiert ist ich sehe keinen
Monat Geld
und das mit zwei Renten
hätte ich auch mal nicht gedacht
es ist heute
beim Bundesgesundheitsminister klingt
das so im Pflegeheim verharrten die
Sozialfälle Zitat auf insgesamt
niedrigem Niveau im stationären Bereich
bezieht etwa ein Drittel ergänzend Hilfe
zur Pflege dieser Anteil ist in den
letzten Jahren nicht gestiegen sondern
gesunken
ich habe mir von dem Herrn Lauterbach
mehr versprochen
aber das ist doch ein Witz wenn das sagt
die werden immer weniger mehr
man sieht doch was hier los ist
das sieht man auch beim Statistischen
Bundesamt von fast 800.000 Heimbewohnern
erhielten zuletzt
335.000 Sozialhilfe das sind mehr als
ein Drittel
42 %. dabei wurde die Pflegeversicherung
mal eingeführt um Sozialfälle zu
verhindern
wie viele die Eigenanteile für
Heimbewohner Deckeln das ist nicht nur
für Pflegeexperten wie Professor rotgang
sondern war auch für Karl Lauterbach mal
die Lösung allerdings war er da noch
nicht Bundesgesundheitsminister wir als
SPD stehen zu diesem Modell ohne wenn
und aber wir finden das richtig wir
haben auch eigene ähnliche Vorschläge
schon in der Vergangenheit gemacht
bisher ist mit der Union da nichts
durchsetzbar wir fragen nach bei Karl
Lauterbach jetzt als Minister ob er an
dem Deckel für Eigenanteile festhält er
arbeite an einer Pflegereform heißt es
Zitat derzeit wird intensiv daran
gearbeitet zu Inhalten oder Zeitplänen
können wir daher zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
keine Auskunft erteilen
ja zuerst mal dass man natürlich zu spät
dran ist und ich fürchte jetzt im ersten
Halbjahr diesen Jahres werden wir wieder
nur kleine Schritte sehen und vor der
Bundestagswahl wird man dann sagen oho
wir haben ein Problem aber jetzt ist
doch Herr Lauterbach Gesundheitsminister
ein echtes Wahlversprechen vor der Wahl
sagt man das eine nach der Wahl tut man
das andere
die Arbeiterwohlfahrt betreibt im
Vogtland sieben Pflegeheime deren
Bewohner schon jetzt so gut 80% auf
Sozialhilfe angewiesen sind und es
werden bald mehr du musst beschreiben du
musst mir nur die Zahl Massen ja die
neuesten Zahlen aus der
Finanzbuchhaltung sagen die Eigenanteile
müssen dieses Jahr um fast 600 Euro
steigen
die Eigenanteile müssen einfach
gedeckelt werden und die Schwester nicht
wo die noch hin sollen und meine
Befürchtungen als Geschäftsführerin sind
wir knacken die 3000 Euro Grenze das
geht nicht das geht einfach nicht das
hat niemand das bringt niemand auf hallo
[Musik]
auch Brigitte Vogt bezog jahrelang
Sozialhilfe nur weil sie im Pflegeheim
lebt jetzt hat sie eine kleine Erbschaft
gemacht doch über das was Lebensgefährte
Karl-heinz hier hinterlassen hat kann
sie nicht frei verfügen die Erbschaft
geht für das Pflegeheim drauf
wenn es Erbe verbraucht ist und dann
muss man sehen dann muss der Virus
ihr Erbe wird nur eine Zeit lang reichen
dann muss Brigitte Vogt wieder zum
Sozialamt
mehr und mehr verschieben sich die
Kosten zu lassen der Pflegebedürftigen
das beobachten Sie hier mit Sorge und
viele müssen im Pflegeheim zum ersten
Mal im Leben Sozialhilfe beantragen also
ich habe ganz oft dass die wirklich
anfangen zu weinen weil sie eben ein
Leben lang gearbeitet haben und jetzt
das nicht finanzieren können drei Leute
die Eigenanteil selber überzeugen können
alle anderen wirklich auf Sozialhilfe
Niveau also wenn ich auf meinen
Rentenbescheid komme
aber werde mir den Heimplatz nicht
leisten können und werde auf meine
Kinder angewiesen sein oder braucht eine
andere Lösung
die Sozialhilfe für die
Geschäftsführerin der AWO Vogtland